The first worm was designed by Robert Morris, Jr. in 1988. The worm
itself had no malicious payload but, it ended up bogging down the machines that
it infected by spawning new processes
uncontrollably and exhausting resources. And at the
time it was released, it affect ten percent of all Internet hosts. It spread,
through three different propagation vectors. The worm
tried to crack passwords ,using a small dictionary
and a publicly readable password file and also
targeted hosts. That were already listed in a
trusted host file, on the machine that was
already infected. This ability to perform remote execution
was one way, that the worm was allowed to spread. The second way that it spread
,was in a buffer overflow vulnerability, In the finger demon. This was a
standard buffer overflow exploid. And ,if you
don't know about buffer overflows, I would
urge you to take a computer security coarse. But essentially, this is a
very common attack that makes remote exploits
possible, effectively resulting in the ability to
run arbitrary code. At the root level
privilege. The third way that worm spread, was
via the debug command in send mail, which
is a mail sending service. In early send
mail versions, it was possible to execute a
command on a remote machine by sending an
SMTP message. The worm used this, capability to
spread automatically. A key theme that we'll see
In the design of other worms, is this
use of multiple vectors. Now any particular worm,
may end up using, a different set of
vectors depending on the remote vulnerabilities that it's trying
to exploit. But the idea that any worm
should be able to exploit multiple weaknesses in a
system gives it more ways to spread. And
often also speeds up the propagation of the worm.
This worm design also followed the following
general approach, which we see showing up over
and over again in worm designs. First, the
worm needs to scan other hosts to find
potentially vulnerable hosts. In the second step, it
needs to spread. By infecting, other vulnerable hosts.
And in the third step, it needs to
remain undiscoverable and undiscovered so that it can
continue to operate and spread without being removed from systems.